the Ringling Brothers and Barnum and
Bailey Circus has folded its tent for
good for nearly 150 years a show dazzled
audiences of all ages but in January the
circus parent company decided it could
not keep juggling the numbers so called
greatest show on earth was also a target
of animal rights groups turning to copal
was at one of the last performances and
shows us what happened at the grand
finale last night Tony good morning good
morning for a long time nothing could
match the thrills let alone challenge
the wonder of the circus animals were
the show's biggest draw for a long time
but in the end they were also its
biggest liability
[Music]
after a night of roaring soaring and
laughter
the Ringling Brothers and Barnum and
Bailey Circus sang its swan song
[Music]
Jonathan Lee Iverson served as
ringmaster of the last show we were a
part of something amazing something that
most people will never experience it's a
time of mourning but it's a time of
celebration to Alexander and KT lacy
were the show's main animal trainers
taming and menagerie of big cats llamas
and a kangaroo greening for me was
always kind of the cream of the crop the
best place to work because of what they
could provide for me and my animals
those animals along with horses and
especially elephants had long been the
show's biggest draw animals are not ours
for entertainment but the circus faced
mounting pressure from animal welfare
activists and last May Feld
Entertainment the company that owns
Ringling Brothers retired its elephants
though it always denied abuse CEO
Kenneth Feld told CBS Sunday morning
that was the beginning of the end for
business we saw a drop in ticket sales
in attendance way beyond what we
anticipated 94 year old selma heller
rode those Ringling elephants as an
acrobat during the 1946 season who do
you think has the better show your show
from 1946 oh yeah your show is better Oh
on Sunday she brought four generations
of her family to say goodbye funny thing
it just may be better sometimes too laid
to rest and let it be the great
experience that we all kind of remember
just let it live as the greatest show
and the end of Ringling Brothers comes
after SeaWorld agreed to phase out its
Orca shows animal rights groups have
taken credit but many of the performers
blame the demise not on animal rights
groups but on technology the smartphone
the greatest show on earth now in the
palm of your hand oh that's that's
that's tough to go miss a circus yeah I
will the circus as a kid and took my own
children but the more you hear about it
I actually understand the decision as
difficult as it is I get it it's more
than just the animals though I mean the
the family that owns Ringling said 250
million people went to the show in the
last 50 years and to think in the next
50 years that number is going to be zero
Wow all right Tony
thank you Sonny